chris hogan here i've spent so much time
on the road and talked with a lot of
people and the millionaire success
stories that i run into might surprise
you most stories that have a happy
ending don't feel like it along the way
you're gonna get a glimpse into the life
of a self-made millionaire what came out
of it was a lot of lessons this is
millionaire my name is Amir and this is
my lovely wife Connie we along with our
two grown children run a consulting firm
where we provide speaking consulting
workshops and those types of services to
two leaders I left Iran because there
was a lot of unrest at the time in 1978
there was a war that was a revolution
there was a lot of stuff that happened
and I didn't make it back home for 13
years Connie came from a background of
very modest means and say the hood okay
my family was lower middle-class I guess
are struggling we struggled the whole
time my parents told me nothing
absolutely nothing about finances and my
parents obviously lived in a completely
different culture they didn't know
anything about this culture and they
weren't here to coach me or teach me or
anything like that so I have to say we
were clueless we had no idea what I mean
about finances about life or anything we
were in love I mean we didn't know
anything about anything we just knew
that we loved each other and we said hey
why not let's go ahead and get married
we were kids at the time I was going to
school I had two jobs and Connie had one
job and between the two of us we had a
car a beater and and so that's where we
were when I got out of college I
remember my salary was about $36,000 a
year okay so for many many years it
wouldn't reach a six-figure salary we
did a lot of stupid with zeros and
as they've mentioned but then later on
in life what we did was we essentially
got a lot smarter about how to manage
our money and the fact that that is not
something that is a good thing and and
and and that's how we really started
making real progress in our finances I
was looking at TV and I saw this reality
show with a family that had a large
amount of kids and someone asked him how
can you afford all these kids and they
said we're debt-free and I'm going like
they're debt-free with all those kids
and we have to we can be debt-free so I
I went on their website I tried to find
out what they did but it wasn't
practical enough it wasn't what I needed
because I needed to how to and then I
discovered a Ramsey I saw his billboards
here in Atlanta and bought the course
and told him here we have to do this I'm
you're had no choice she is an avid
reader on a variety of topics and when
she came to this one she was like look
we got to do this we took the course and
really found the principles to be very
helpful and so we started coordinating
about nine years ago FPU and in fact
even right now as we speak on Monday
nights we are coordinating our I think
our tenth class having a budget having a
plan having some sort of a discipline to
do that those are basically foundational
things that need to happen
what are some things that really
contribute it to us getting there for me
the first thing is stop chasing the next
hot stock I cannot tell you how many bad
decisions I made it was like geez every
time we heard about something is really
doing great we jumped on the bandwagon
only to see a tank we're gonna put our
money in long-term you know mutual funds
and we're not gonna chase that next
thing so the second thing I would say
that is really critical for anybody who
wants to be a millionaire if you will
you need to decide if you want to be
wealthy or if you want to look wealthy
if you decide that you want to look
wealthy to others then chances are
there's gonna take you a long time and
you may not ever get there when you have
a scarcity mentality you feel like
there's only so much of this to go
around and it really causes you to be
greedy to hold on to things not to give
anything not to because then you're
gonna have less but have an abundance
mentality the more you give the more
will come your way we really made a
commitment to ourselves to have this
house be a blessing to other people so
we have helped countless classes in our
basement for people who wanted guidance
on finances I do a lot of coaching on
leadership and that sort of thing from
time to time we've known people who
needed a place to stay for a period of
time
the other way that we try to do that is
you know I'm a I'm a consultant I'm a
speaker and I have a lot of friends who
do the same thing and what I do is I
recommend their work they recommend my
work is not like okay we're competitors
and if you have more I'm gonna have less
so I think this whole notion of having
an abundance mentality makes you a giver
and it opens up a lot of doors that
otherwise would be closed more and more
as we're exposed to people who have
accumulated millions of dollars we are
now very clear that it's not about how
much money you make it's about how much
of that money you keep because even when
we did hit six-figure for quite some
time we were actually just spending the
money we weren't keeping in yeah but
yeah we save we have targets we have a
plan and we adjust our spending as we
need to
so if your Excuse is you know I grew up
in this kind of environment you can
overcome it if your excuse is I don't
make a lot of money you really can
overcome that by going after something
that you love to do to increase the
amount of money that you make but at the
same time most importantly keeping more
of the money that you do make and if
your excuse is while I'm too old for
this stuff but we've had people in our
classes were in their 60s and 70s and
yes we have those conversations that
says oh geez I wish I had started when I
was 20 but you know what I can start now
it doesn't matter what kind of adversity
you're dealing with if you're hoping if
you really have hope for a brighter
future that fact in itself transforms
who you are in this moment and what you
do and how much enthusiasm you live your
life with so my encouragement to the
viewers would be adopt a an abundance
mentality if you don't have all the
tools and methodologies go after it
there's plenty of learning I mean you
can start with a Financial Peace
University it's only nine weeks what are
you gonna do for nine weeks take the
course and make it happen
it's possible so go for it and I
certainly wish all the viewers the best
because it is possible that they will be
in the same seat that we're in telling
their story
[Music]
you